it takes a long time to make a film i
want to be fascinated
by that journey i was getting an awful
lot of sort of
you know patronizing kind of pats on the
head and
hang in there and that's not what i
wanted to hear at all
some of us are jerks some of us are
talkative some are very quiet
um none of that really matters very much
the big thing is taste taste and
judgment most people get their first
chance
to direct by blackmailing their way in
generally they have to say well if you
want me to write the script
you've got to let me direct it want me
to act in the movie you got to let me
direct it keep building a spec
you know or an outline or something so
you're collecting your own
intellectual property at all times
[Music]
it takes a long time to make a film i
want to be fascinated
by that journey in a project like
hillbilly elegy it was relatability i
love family stories
but i've i've never had one that was a
true story that
dealt with characters from rural america
and that's my family's background i grew
up in california but my mom and dad are
from the midwest
i felt like i just connected with these
these characters this family dynamic and
journey the ways in which they were
funny
the dramas that they had to work through
and of course the always relatable
journey
of a young guy discovering himself
understanding the strengths that he's
inherited but also overcoming some of
the baggage
you got to think about these kids what
do you think i've been thinking about
since i was 18 years old huh the biggest
thing is to never stop
writing you know keep building a spec
you know or an outline or something so
you're collecting your own intellectual
property at all times
you know even while you're you're going
out and starting to take meetings now
the development game
is not what it once was and even though
you have some heat from having something
optioned
you want to take advantage of every one
of those get to know you meetings that
you possibly can
and open up relationships with
development executives because
that's so important interesting rewrite
jobs might come your way
those are great for paying the bills but
more importantly you know you're
developing
relationships with the gatekeepers the
people who will
can can help you you know get things
done
that's really important but vital is
to not just have you know one calling
card okay you've got an option that's
great
it's you want to just keep being as
productive as you can
and collaborating and as this one
that's been optioned moves forward my
suggestion would be
to stay as nimble and loose about
um continuing to collaborate and take on
collaborators it's been your baby
but that's not really the way film works
you know
now there are two or three key voices
that often enter into
the evolution of a screenplay and you
know
the collaborators
directors producers studio executives
love somebody who can continue to
advance
by you know having that creative
conversation taking some notes
building upon the good ones and being
smart about editing out and weeding out
the ideas that are
you know that are not compatible with
the with the screenplay so the more you
can
demonstrate that you know the more you
just build goodwill and your own that
own create
that muscle that uh that most great
screenwriters need to have
as a young person a young adult trying
to make the transition from sitcom actor
to motion picture director well i mean
i was getting an awful lot of sort of
you know patronizing
kind of pats on the head and hang in
there and you know in another 10 or 15
years i'm
you know i'm sure somebody will give you
a chance to direct and that's not what i
wanted to hear
at all so
i had a lot of frustration about that
and i kind of earned my way out by
by making student films myself by
writing
and by being fortunate enough to put
myself
get myself into a position of of some
leverage
by being one of the lead actors on happy
days
i had some leverage it's had something i
could sort of trade with most people get
their first chance
to direct by blackmailing their way in
generally they have to say well if you
want me to write the script
you got to let me direct it if you want
me to act in the movie you got to let me
direct it
you know if if you want this money
this group of investors that i've found
you're gonna have to let me direct the
film
and and that's nobody really wants to
hand a first-time director
the reigns you know directors some of
them
some of us are sweethearts some of us
are jerks
some of us are talkative some are very
quiet
um none of that really matters very much
although i
you know i always i always think that
it's nice to be decent to people
but that's me uh it's not imperative
the big thing is taste taste and
judgment that's what it's all about and
it's it's uh
it's understanding you know what's
what exists within the possibilities of
the story you're interested in telling
you know and and and and how many of
those details can you capture
how can you sequence them together in
the editing you know what does that add
up to
and um it really doesn't much matter how
you get there
whether there's a large crew or a small
crew whether it takes a long time or
just a little while
but what it really matters is what did
you get and what does it mean to other
people when you
edit it together and share it with them
i think that the number one
lesson probably was that trying to
achieve a quality
entertainment is something that requires
incredibly diligent focus and dedication
andy embodied that and at the same time
you could work hard on the creative
problem solving you could
you could respect the audience and and
try to
achieve a level of quality but you could
also have fun
and laugh and that in fact the creative
collaborative uh energy could be
really intoxicating and thrilling to be
around but it also
required this sort of equilibrium
between
focus professionalism and an ongoing
sense of play
because you are you are engaging in
in sort of make-believe to try to help
achieve the
the goals of any scene no matter what
the genre well
we were trying to do um
internet content starting like about
99 89. yeah i think it was 99
and dreamworks and imagine combined on a
thing called pop.com
which was sort of gonna had we kept it
going which we didn't it might have
grown into sort of youtube i mean it was
that idea
of making short films for the internet
creating an environment where people
could upload their
their short films and and things like
that
and um and it you know we couldn't get
it to work
we we started it it failed just didn't
make business sense
we were out in front of it and cost too
much and stuff like that so
um but but
it in my mind i felt like
there was a maybe a a new kind of
um lower cost sort of
television that could be produced that
would
utilize
the the the of a new kind of visual
vocabulary
that was coming out of reality
television
um and docutv like sort of like cops
but also the reality tv show and
i'd done ed tv which was about a reality
i mean it was before reality tv shows
existed um
the notion of just following people
around and uh
and and and sort of you know ntv they're
they're they're airing it live uh
but um i felt like that there was a
a way to do a sitcom
that would feel very spontaneous and
and and could be dense
comedically dense because you could do
more visual humor you could be more
cinematic
you could do you could have a narrator
you could do flashbacks you could
you could uh let person say a person say
one thing and then you could expose them
for the hypocrites that they are with a
quick flashback
you know and things like that and and um
and it could be a sort of you know a
modern
[Music]
more cinematic approach to a sitcom but
it would have to be genuinely funny not
just smug
when you're doing something as
emotionally um
risky um as as
you know sort of working on a tv show or
or or a movie i mean part of it is that
you're
you're you're facing yeah the real
possibility of
complete public humiliation i mean it's
not all that unusual for people to just
say oh that was terrible
did you see that guy he's oh he was
awful
see steaks and and so everybody knows
that that's out there
because they've participated in that
same kind of kind of
ragging on on uh shows and movies they
know they know you're
that that you're putting yourself you
know up for that sort of um
that sort of judgment you're opening
yourself so as a result
you know there there does need to be a
kind of trust but i found that in the
creative community there's often a
sort of an instant trust and you can
either
in in just one or two conversations you
can actually determine
whether that trust exists um
in you know in a relationship or not my
first movie was a
car chase comedy young people on the run
called grand theft auto
and made for 602 thousand dollars but
the film made a terrific profit
and it got me started i had to i wrote
it with my father
um and and i had to star in it in order
to get to
to direct it but that's the last time
that i acted in anything that i directed
one of the things that i suggest to
almost anybody and i do it myself
from time to time is whatever the genre
if there's a movie and there's a there's
a that you particularly like and there
are sequences
that you remember and and you think are
cool
watch them over and over again watch
them a couple of times
with sound and then watch them a couple
of times without sound because when you
pull the sound out
which is like the final finish that
really in a lot of ways brings a lot of
you know gives a lot of the impact to a
scene you also begin to see
really how the filmmakers captured those
images
did they use the same shots over and
over and keep cutting back to them
was it always a different shot on a
different angle is the camera moving
is it static you know what's the what's
the language
that they're using and what does it mean
and it answers so many questions because
we sort of understand movies intuitively
but when you really start breaking them
down and understanding what was done
on the day to create that that sequence
of shots that we love
that meet that has an impact on us you
know it's like a light goes off you just
begin it simplifies
everything it removes a lot of the
mystery anybody can shoot anything
but it's how you how you begin to build
it and piece it together that i think
means the most
and uh of course the the editorial
software is so
cool now that you know anybody should
take advantage of that
and um you know and start putting
together putting together our images
the first thing that i do when i step on
set is usually hand off my shot list to
the script supervisor
or if i haven't built my shot list yet
and all i have is a bunch of notes
is uh you know i'm bypassing you know
uh stop off at the porta potty uh
and get a cup of coffee that's kind of
obvious early in the morning
uh but um get out there
look at the set get a quick report if
there are any surprises
um is anybody sick are your actors okay
is everybody on time uh is what's the
weather supposed to be
you get a quick you know rundown then
you see if the plan that you made
the the day before still holds so you
know your first shot's going to be
and and then it's really about getting
that first shot launched sometimes that
entails getting the actors there for a
rehearsal first
sometimes you know what the staging is
going to be and you get the camera crew
going
and then you you know you begin the the
process if i haven't made a shot list
once i've staged that first one and
broken it all down
i'll step aside with the script
supervisor and and jot down
a shot list for the entire day could be
up to 50 shots
but i'll work it out with him or her
and and that's usually about 75
accurate in terms of what we're really
going to do but it becomes a great
organizing game plan
at 65 ron howard continues to exhibit a
youthful exuberance
for many americans he knows he is
forever opie
in reflecting on his latest documentary
subject luciano pavarotti
howard focused on the tenor's drive and
willingness to take risks
you come across as an easy-going person
right that's been your
that was your actor persona as well but
there's clearly some
driver ambition or even is there a
killer instinct in there that well only
a
respect for the medium i mean i think
that look pavarotti was
he he was charming people loved working
with him
they really wanted to work with him you
know i hope people feel that way about
working with me
i bring a lot of joy and excitement to
the set with me because
uh you know that's the way i feel you're
65 you've been at this a long time
61 of 65 but you seem to be busier than
ever
as a storyteller um it's
it's uh it's almost like this buffet uh
it's
it's uh um incredibly energizing
to me all right ron howard thank you
very much pleasure
thanks
you